Ty y here I am here with BuzzFeed
answering your questions on whatever
this is called Puppy Playhouse what is
it called Puppy interview puppy
Playhouse bring me the puppies
welcome hello
guys oh I can't answer any questions
there another one surrounded oh hey hy
oh guys I really needed you
[Music]
come my least favorite memory from
directing next go winds was getting cica
and not being able to walk through the
entire shoes who cares about that who
cares about anything anymore and my most
favorite was just being in Hawaii the
sun went down we got to go and hang out
at the beach and I get Adam Sandler now
I get
it I like watching the World Cup but I
don't follow any teams like in the UK or
anything like that or champions league
and Premiership stuff I just like
watching games from time to time so I
didn't really follow soccer that much
coming from croud rugby playing nation
in New
[Music]
Zealand oh my god well there was a great
documentary called Next go wins um about
the team it's a true story about worst
football team in the world amazing
marginal Life characters and an
incredible Underdog Story yes it
[Music]
is I'm always saded to see things cut
but it's also necessary for the story
you have to get rid of the stuff can't
keep everything in your in your films I
don't understand why people put deleted
scenes on things deleted for a reason
they weren't good
enough I think just one with like a lot
of moving elements like lot there's lots
of coverage and lots of people um and
this film at any given moment is usually
around 10 10 to 20 people in you've seen
and uh so that takes a lot of time doing
it uh maybe something I grew up with
like um Mash no chips chips California
Highway Patrol I direct an episode of
that cuz I love John
[Music]
punch animal lovers film a dog film I
would love to do a dog like mie and Me
part two four
mes I don't know I've worked with so
many great actors now and I I tend to
like them all actors are just a
interesting bunch of people much like
puppies you've got to um engage with
them you got to give them toys to play
with they're Dopey but lovable and it's
very hard to get them to
[Music]
concentrate I'd love to work with Liam
Liam's a good mate and it's only a
matter of time before we go all three of
them in one project how's that Three
Musketeers big fan of Cool Runnings Bad
News Bears what's the other one Miracle
brilliant I'm sure there's one that's
like super obvious that I've missed
out well getting married was fantastic
look that yeah my kids were there and we
did it very privately and just timate
ceremony hardly anyone there yeah it's
very it's a very special
day well I'm a big fan of purple rain as
a karaoke number not going to sing it
for
you I think play all my my aunties
equally as good as each other and what
they cook in New Zealand out in the
country where we grow up there's a great
dish called boilup which is like a big
broth full of Bones and vegetables and
stuff and um sounds simple but it's not
but it's just one of the best meals um
uh and it's my favorite
meal my primary source of inspiration I
think is uh people I like to look at
people and observe them and um I just
find them fascinating especially
families uh most of my films are about
families or versions of families and
it's a never- ending source of
entertainment and
inspiration what have you heard what
rumors have you guys heard what is
this is ENT trapment
you guys got me in here soften me up
with these dogs and you trying to get
rumors out of me um I don't listen to
rumors um I just start them this dog's a
backstabber this dog was talking about
hey this one was talking about you guys
behind your back that's what I do that's
what I do with all the Hollywood parties
sh was talking about
you I don't know what is that food I
just love hanging out I love hanging out
and talking I love food dinners where
you guys going
going eat the food because it's better
than here fresh air going out to the
beach and uh just getting into nature
and hanging out with my family come in
come in here you guys come and do this
Arro with me guys thanks so much for
watching uh puppy interviews with me and
these four lunatics please go and see my
new film next gold wins uh out in
theaters I also we these guys need some
homes there's a great shelter Northshore
Justice League of America puppy shelter
something like that and uh just go on to
the website which is right
there